هذه الجبال العراقيه الواقعه في المثلث
العراقي التركي الايراني التي شهدت قبل
ايام قصف تركيا عنيفا مستهدفين مواقعها
حزب العمال الكردستاني المعارض لانقره ومن
السلسله الجبال قنديل المتاخمه للاراضي
الايرانيه
[موسيقى]
لم يبقى لدى اسماعيل زردلي صور ذكرياته
لمنزله وقريته في بلدتي بالقرب من جبال
قنديل الحدوديه مع ايران وذلك بعد ان
هجرها وعائلته وجميع سكان قريته بسبب
القصف التركي الذي تسببها بمقتل سته من
اقاربه عام 2015 ومنذ ذلك الحين طروا من
قريتهم وحتى الان الى مناطق اكثر امنا
شماليه اربيل همم 2012 قوات الايرانيه
سيطره على مناطق جبال القنديل اا حتى الان
همم بعد مساء في هذه المنطقه ليس همم امان
وليس همم
همم استقرار في هذه المناطقنا اكثر من 60
قريه كرديه اجبرت المقاتلات تركيات سكانها
على النزوح الى عمق الاراضي العراقيه في
هذه البلده لوحدها حسب مدير ناحيه ورتي
القريبه من الحدود العراقيه الايرانيه
اكثر من 63
تابعه للناحيه تورته 61 قريه تابعه همم
الناحيه الثانيه بحدود منطقه قنديل
هذه القرى طبعا طبعا اكثر هذه طبعا نازحه
ما بيها اي احد لانها تخافوا على
الراحهم
بذلك نصحت الى مناطق الاكثر امانا يشار
الى ان سلسله جبال قنديل الحدوديه مع
ايران ما تزال خارج السيطره للحكومه
الاتحاديه واقليم كردستان العراق منذ اكثر
من ثلاثه عقود وتمتاز بالجغرافيتها
الجبليه الواعره جدا ويتخذ منها مسلحو حزب
العمال كردستان المعارض لانقرا والمدعوم
من الحرس الثوري الايراني ملاذات امينه
لهم منذ بدايه التسعينات القرن الماضي من
الحدود العراقيه الايرانيه احمد الحمدانيه
العربيه